there's a little more walking phoenix
Joker news crossing my path so I guess
I'll just do a review at night school so
what I do when there's no Joker news I
guess night school tonight schools
directed by the director of curls trip
which I really like Kevin Hart
essentially plays I want to say pond man
but he just lied to his girlfriend about
how successful he is in life he's a con
man so in order for him to get a better
job he needs to get his GED from high
school so he enters night class in which
Tiffany Haddish is the teacher but he
doesn't tell his girlfriend about it's
up to here we go bring on the comedy
it's kind of like Billy Madison only not
half as fun Tiffany Haddish and Kevin
Hart had moments of fun they had moments
of Sun good back and forth we're talking
a percentage of it the rest of it was
what looked like ad lib but just came
across as awkward like Tiffany Haddish
his character in the movie there's no
nonsense person it has a heart of gold a
Kevin Hart plays Kevin Hart Kevin Hart I
think is funny a lot of people are sick
of him and I totally get that but I'm
the kind of person who can listen to the
same song on repeat for an hour long car
ride so obviously it takes a lot for me
to get sick of people and things Kevin
Hart is not there for me I think he's
funny he's great in Jumanji this movie
just does him no favors if for nothing
else this movie comes across like Kevin
Hart can't do ad lib or at least
shouldn't have those moments where it
stays on a joke for too long this is a
big problem in this movie this movie
will find a joke and just stay on it for
an uncomfortably long amount of time it
goes for scenes it goes for jokes like
the introduction to the class which is
the most development most members of the
class get it was there for so long it
just felt so long because it just wasn't
a funny scene it wasn't an interesting
saying the characters don't interest you
the jokes don't make you laugh you just
want to move on but just stays there
granted it should stay on some form of
development but I just don't know or
care about the characters like remember
that movies summer school with mr. Shoop
you did well if you don't I do so I'm
gonna compare it to that after watching
that movie about 20 years ago I've
remembered the classmates or at least a
number of them more than I remembered in
this movie anyway maybe the problem is
the fact that some of these supporting
classmates they're not young they're not
spry except for one of them's young but
again she gets like no time to shine oh
yes they're going to night school to
better themselves sure but they don't
have hopes and dreams like after they
realize we're not gonna be actors and
directors and they just settled into
their boring lives and even the most
they can hope for is a pretty basic
office job that's where we are with them
which I suppose simply means making a
school comedy about a
else is just harder than making it about
you but it's still doable you can still
make it interesting they just didn't
also some of the editing was off what
the [ __ ] was some of this editing in the
trailer to this movie the blade Shia I
can't think of her name I don't have my
phone with me either she plays Chloe
from 24 she says something about quit
but like a walnut in this movie they
edit that out she says I want to crack
it like a walnut but the cameras
straight up on her and you can read her
lips she does not say it I guess but was
okay for the hardcore trailer but not
for the actual movie I don't get why it
was edited out such profanity I've seen
this a lot like a movie can have one or
two like speed has it Dennis hoppers on
the phone with Jack and he says all
right but I want you back here real fast
but it's mouse says I want you back your
son of a [ __ ] Revenge of the Sith
hazard what things so I mean they're
there they're out there they happen in
movies but it's usually not so obvious
over something so trivial like the word
but here's a mind-blowing fact I've
actually done that in some reviews I've
had to edit the audio in some way
sometimes it's Miri pronouncing
something making something a plural but
it should have been a singular or
vice-versa and you slip the audio in
there and you blend it hopefully no one
notices generally speaking no one said
anything so that's good but if I were to
blatantly alter the audio in which you
could just see it not line up with my
mouth that would make it really really
awkward like maybe I noticed because I
edit my videos and having the audio and
video line up it's kind of the name of
the game I'm conditioned to notice that
kind of stuffs maybe other people won't
notice but I notice it and I'm doing
this review so it bothered me it's not
just that one thing there are other
editing calls in this movie I just had
to go how why like there's a scene in
the movie where Kevin Hart's gonna get
this thing and then he can't get the
thing and then there's a montage of him
doing something in which he can get the
thing and then he gets the thing the
difference between the movie just giving
him the thing and not giving him the
thing having a montage in him then
getting the thing is a montage the
difference is the movies not three
minutes longer it was useless guys in
the night school MIT wasn't that good I
like Tiffany Haddish I like Kevin Hart
apparently I like them in separate
movies either didn't work too well
together or the movie just wasn't
constructed in a way that would allowed
them to but the movie wasn't funny
couple of chuckles sure got most of the
comedy either came in flat or came
across as awkward I'm just saying I'm
not gonna remember this one in t-minus
one day yep already four guys this is
where I realized I could've just stayed
home and done a video on that bumblebee
trailer live and learn I guess right so
night school have you seen it what did
you think about it or what's your
favorite school
ever whatever it is what everything
comment below let me know and as always
if you like what you seen here and you
want to see more click right here to see
more
[Music]